a warm welcome to everyone here
in the hall a warm welcome to
everyone in the digital space we are
very pleased that you are here with us today d
to know need to know want to know that
is the motto of this Berlin science week
and when we talk about knowledge about  If we talk about knowledge,
then there are institutions that
somehow feel responsible for it
and I think we as
universities and universities of
applied sciences have that to a very
special extent and with the knowledge that
we produce every day, I
think we also have a special
responsibility  accompanied by a responsibility
for our society a
responsibility for our democracy and
responsibility is certainly still being
discussed today when it comes to how
much data collection should be allowed. I am
very much looking forward to the podium today. I would like to
thank our
moderator Vivian upuppmann and my
colleagues and  Colleagues from the HTW Berlin
and D64, I wish you all an
exciting discussion and perhaps you will
hear my voice again
if you participate today with questions.
I can then present them
and address them to the podium, so please
participate actively  slido
are you there discuss with
us we are looking forward
to it,
thank you very much for the introduction
from me too, a
warm or warm welcome to everyone
who is here, everyone who is at home,
my name is wiin upuppmann, I'm
moderating today and I'm such a person
a bit the one who will keep an eye on the time
and who is also there
to see whether you have any questions, whether we can
ask any questions here, you
can do it later in the room
and you can also do it via
slido, so that's very easy
Now just quickly scan the code if you
want to join in and then you can get rid of the
questions online.
I hope I'm easy to
understand and then I'm not left to
do the whole thing alone, but of
course I would like to invite guests onto the stage
while I briefly introduce  If
you want to say sentences, you can
come to me and I'll be with Professor Dr
Helena Michaljewitsch, she's a
professor of data science at the HTW
Berlin, she's a mathematician and researches,
among other things, in the area of
privacy-sensitive mobility data
About it, if you like and find it,
we can also find out, among other things, what
insights we can have from personal
data for our society
and what we can do with it.
Also there is Professor Dr
wtech drabrowski, he is a professor of
applied computer science at the HTW and
conducts research  especially in the area of
biomedical images and
information processing, it's about
the potential for the
benefits that
data can bring to society as a whole, but also
about the risks of use and,
above all, about medical data.
I'm still covering it now, but
we'll see it in a moment  long enough
m
Unfortunately, I have to apologize to Professor Dr Claudia Millerbn, she ca
n't attend at short notice today, that
's very sorry for her, but I think we
'll still make good use of the time
with her help and with the help of our
guests. I'm still missing one, please come to me
Selz is a software
developer who is also a
board member of the
digital policy association D64 for
digital progress and
this association regularly questions
what risks the storage of
personal data entails and
what data protection standards
should also be used by companies, including in the
interests of us
consumers and for that reason
I'm happy that everyone is there, I'll take a
seat then we can get
started. Maybe you've
seen that there's not only slido,
but that you also have red and green
cards or orange and green cards
on your chair, which you can use
right away  We
thought we would also like to
ask you something and
we would ask everyone who
is here to take part and say do
they actually accept cookies or let's
say all cookies when you
go to a website, just hand on
heart red or  green Yes or No small
picture of the mood thank you for the
honest part name and second question do
you use the same
password everywhere very honest people here in the
audience we are very happy
thank you very much I think there is someone who would like to
say something directly about it
so I was actually extremely
happy how  A lot of red cards
went up means that the
audience, at least on site,
is well informed. I don't know what it
looked like online, but that's
actually a very big problem,
especially nowadays in IT security
because it's the standard attack that a
cybercriminal makes if any
site  was cracked somewhere and the
passwords and usernames
came out. You take this
entire list with all usernames and
passwords and try to log in to
all
services with these username password
combinations on all websites that exist.
It's called credential stuffing, so if I
use the same username password combination everywhere or the
classic I have a secure password
a semi-secure and insecure password
for where it doesn't matter
the most secure password is just as
secure as the most insecure site on
which I have used and
as soon as it has been cracked that's it
compromised where I used the password
um it's one of the
big contributions to identity theft that's why
I'm always happy when
I see root cards and I'm even
happier when people use password managers
very nice here someone next to
me immediately smiled and laughed
I heard briefly, is there anything else
to add? No, there's not much to
add. I can actually
only agree with that, it's a very,
very important topic and I think it
's actually one of the easiest
things that you
can actually do as a private person because even if you do
For many things I have to
trust a company or someone to whom I give my data that the
person or organization
will handle my data responsibly.
This is a date where I
can really decide for myself exactly how secure
I want it to be and it
definitely works out  Maybe it makes sense
to make a little more effort than
choosing the path of least resistance.
Now you've just mentioned something we
all know: we often have to
give companies our data, so
we can't avoid it when we
book a trip  we book a rental car
when we book a train ticket
or something like that we at least give our
name we give a password
we maybe give an address
a
telephone number what happens to
our data and what shouldn't
happen
um that's difficult to answer in general of
course  God, I hope
I don't say this sentence every time,
but it's true and
of course we don't necessarily know much about
which business interests which
company has in which data,
but in fact it's the case that
this happens regularly, that data is
collected by us  not only for
this one purpose that we think
they are being used for,
but also for other
purposes. Most of the time I
actually agree to this by
clicking on certain boxes and saying yes, yes, it's okay,
finally take my data, I
finally want to  That's what I
went to this site for and
use this service for, um but you should be
aware of that. An example
of this is
telecommunications data. You can't
really say who sells it in
what form and according to what so-called
anonymization procedures,
but the fact is you can  e.g.
buy aggregated telecommunications data and that's something that
I think most people are surprised about
because they think I've only
taken out a telephone contract and it's
only used for billing my
customer account or something similar, that
's not the case in the preparation
so basically when I  When I prepare for something like this,
I
of course also do a bit of research on my guests
and find out what's the
best thing to talk to them about. I
saw from Ms. Miichaljewitsch
that they have a project, for example, that
's still current where they or  I do
n't know if it's already completed
then you have to say straight away where you've
also taken on the challenge of data protection-compliant traffic counting through image recognition
You
probably spend a lot of time
looking at how you can anonymize data
and then still use it so that it
does something good for our society, how
difficult is it? So there are
different methods, for example,
to count traffic and
one of them with, you would say, God
how  Can this be data protection compliant How
can this be privacy sensitive? Is it
actually possible to use camera systems
because you can now use
so-called computer vision algorithms,
i.e. these are algorithms that are
able to extract from your video stream
how many people have
crossed an imaginary line, have
driven
and  also what kind of objects they were in,
so was it a bus, that
was a car, that was a truck, a
motorcycle, a bicycle, person on foot,
now also person in a wheelchair,
stroller and the like depending on
which provider and which model, um
you can do it  But now we even
make it so that this happens in real time
and you don't have to save the images separately, which
means you actually only count
how many representatives of a class.
That sounds a bit silly now,
but how many representatives of cars,
bicycles, etc. are now over  I
drove this line that interests me
or over several lines in an
intersection or
something interesting you can of course
do with it would now be an example. You
look at the Ernst Reuterplatz, which I
think is something like that from the
perspective, a very complicated
matter. You would like to know
where it comes from  the vehicles come
in, where do they go out at what time of day
I could actually
do that pretty well
without even saving this data,
so I don't have any
personal data that I have
saved on any hard drive
because this sort of thing now really
works in real time, we don't have a system
The models have been developed for
several years now, but
we have looked at how well
they work, how well we can
now actually use them in reality,
how much the whole thing costs, can
I put it on a very cheap device,
the algorithms are
less common  analyze the pictures
etc and yes, actually,
you can do that pretty well,
especially in the introduction we
heard that universities also
have certain responsibilities and that they
also want to face and face this responsibility.
Now I'll take a look right
over here at our two representatives in von
the HTV if you do research with them then
you are always
aware of this responsibility and spend a
lot of time on anonymization or how
does that work in
research that depends very much on the area
so what I do is I work
primarily with genomic data
and  The question of
anonymization and what can be
passed on begins before the
data has even been obtained.
Accordingly, I do
n't actually use any data in my work where
it would be relevant at all whether people
have consented or not because of their
personal data  The data is already out there,
when you
work with clinics there are always
situations where
you have to say yes, it's good, you don't need to tell me any more,
I don't need the data, I
don't need it to be in the table,
I just need it  Um, sometimes
the feeling for it isn't
present everywhere, but as a rule
it works
pretty well, at least with genomic data, because
somehow this feeling
is also present in society. My genome is
the most personal data I have
and I don't want that  with all the
parts, that's why I'm lucky enough to
rarely be at a loss, so to speak,
because I can see things that I would
n't otherwise be able to see. Things
were a
little different in my previous life, where I actually
got data from the clinic every now and then  I
evaluated it to find out, for example,
whether someone has a certain
disease or something like that and there was
a really strong topic. I have the
data. I should check whether the person
has tuberculosis
I could do more trivially with one keystroke. I won't look at whether
the person has HIV. I won't
look at whether they are at risk of
developing Alzheimer's in 10 years and and and
and on the one hand I'm not allowed to do it and on the
other hand I would do the same to the person
I'm not doing any favors, there is the right not to know in
medicine. I can decide for myself
whether I want to find out about a certain diagnosis,
accidental diagnosis,
or not, because it
's not always entirely clear what
a person's mental health would do if they were told and
conveyed  By the way, we found
out by chance that you will die in 5 years
because you have this mutation
and at your age you get
something where you die after 5 years. That
's a complex topic. I can see that
our time is limited here. I thought
we had it  a certain amount of time but
we can't manage to discuss everything,
but it's nice that we've already
addressed it if there
are questions about it, you'll always somehow notice that there's
a microphone going around afterwards. We
can then discuss it here or
post it on slido  Something else
to add, it's actually part of
medical practice, so if I
go somewhere and then
somehow a major
blood test is done and I
wasn't told beforehand what
could be found out, then
I basically agreed that
everything would be told to me  what will be found out
or so I'm not of course
something else now that means I can't
say 100% how exactly it
's regulated legally but as I
understand it, during the
examination they say
you have a cough because of me and
a differential diagnosis is necessary whether  that is
tuberculosis or a tumor, which means
that a corresponding sample is
taken and then a cross is put on a sheet.
Please examine this sample
for tumor and tuberculosis
differential diagnosis and then it is
sent to the laboratory. The doctor tells you
that is what is going on with the dat  A
sample is taken and the laboratory is
not allowed to examine anything other than exactly
what was marked on the piece of paper and
you may also get the question: is
the data allowed? Additional
data can be collected from the sample and
used for research purposes
and then it will be clarified what is happening
and  so on but that's a completely
different topic that's not
part of the routine, so to speak, okay, I think we
also have to clarify and
I think the expert is sitting next to me like M
is valuable because our data is
actually and are there more valuable than
others
depends  Yes, it always depends on
who has this data and what the
person wants to do with it and I
think that what makes genomic data
very exciting is that I ca
n't change this data myself,
which I have and I ca
n't change it against  I can change my password
is a date of mine that
I can change, so once it
's out then I change it
and so the risk is
relatively low for me, but I can't change my
genomic data if it
's public  Change them,
they always remain mine and
therefore the risk with this data is
of course significantly higher and that
perhaps makes it
more valuable. Otherwise I think it depends
a lot on what I
want to do with it
if that's what I'm concerned about  to
say I want to observe mobility behavior
then the data
may not be that valuable for me
where was I how often did I
walk across the 1st ruterplatz that may
but if you if you if you if
you are interested in exactly this data
that is a  very valuable
date it always depends on
the point of view mhm in the
club in which you are a board member D64
it is so that, for example, they spoke out against data retention at the time and
the club also
sued against it, what is that, what do you advise, so
to speak
Nowadays, users know how they should handle data
and is that also part of the
association to do educational work in this way? It is
important to say that
we are a purely voluntary association with
almost 800 members and with us
the volunteers contribute to the content, what does that
mean?  If a member is interested in
a certain topic, then
we work on it. If no one is interested
or has expertise in it, then there is
no position on it.
Accordingly, some topics do
not have educational work on others
and we are always fundamentally
trying to empower
consumers
Consciously think about why? Who am
I sharing this date with and
why am I doing this and what could that
person do with it? What does that mean for
me? That is of course a
basic attitude that we try to
convey and when it comes to
data retention we
specifically said okay  In this case,
the state would like to have a
large amount of data for which for the
vast majority and we are really talking
about well over 99% of people there is
simply no reason
to have this data and for the absolutely
small proportion for whom it makes sense
or where this data
can be helpful, there are no
really verifiable studies that show that
the data is useful in any way
because most
security authorities
are not able to process this amount of data
or at least they were at the
time that we said
That's just a
totally inappropriate reason for encroaching on
fundamental rights and that's why
we're against it, we've sued against it and
fortunately the European
Constitutional Court has largely ruled in our favor. Yes,
I think that's the main problem
and I'm now
also concluding that for everyone else
We often don't even know what data
we are giving out and why, so this question
about the cookies, for example, just now, where everyone
answered honestly,
I think that's one of the main things: you go
somewhere, you click on it, yes you accept it,
but what exactly do you do with the data?  What
happens even if you
read through it is actually
relatively non-transparent is what you
would all say now, yes
something really needs to be done about it, the
consumers inside need to find out more and with
more transparency
what is happening with the data, yes,
clearly  Okay, I, I, I can, I can
only speak for myself.
I've been dealing with
tracking in online services for years, I've only
worked for a provider like this myself, now
from a different perspective, so to speak, where
we can also get very actively involved as an association
against it  Simply
say, I've been dealing with this for years
and I
don't understand exactly what's going on because the market is intentionally opaque, which is why it's sometimes incomprehensible that it's
such a highly concentrated market
and that's why I think it's virtually
impossible to know who
I mean  data when I visit a website
and that is of course
something that we definitely criticize at first
and we encounter a lot of
resistance, but you have to say very clearly
that I think it is very difficult
given the current model of how large parts
of the Internet currently work
Getting away from it is
a huge challenge when it
comes to the topic, it's
obvious that there are risks and criticism that you can
do a lot  Amounts of
data used, what can you
do with it, can you use it to save the world,
can you make our society
better, what's so great about data,
well, it's, um, of course here
at marketingden you really have to come
up with a lot of things to be able to,
um, for
society as a whole
To find a positive progressive purpose, it is
clearly a monetary purpose that may
be justified for your company to
want to earn money by finding out who it is
best to target with advertising,
but
for me as a private person it is not something
that I
would like to support in a big way, there are
other areas  where the
topic becomes more difficult I'll now go back
to the mobility area
we all have to clarify it again
where we also have data collected all the time
and also have a direct benefit
from it if I act as a
driver, which I am not  I do
n't have my own car but if I were to
drive through Berlin now I would
probably do it with a Google Maps
navigation. The fact that they are
like this is a good thing that this
data is available and that it
can be navigated at a fairly precise time
in terms of traffic planning  It's
important to know which
connections are overloaded, which ones are
what time, how many people go in
and out, but I can also
make this relatively privacy-sensitive.
Another area in which we also work is
the area of
personnel selection. That's where things get
Complicated personnel selection is a
very sensitive area, there's a
lot at stake, whether I get a job
or not is highly relevant to
my livelihood, personal
development, etc. I don't need to
tell anyone, but it's well known that in the
personnel selection market
it's not always the case  is fair
and discrimination is something that
some groups of people experience more often.
Now it is also a market in which
technologies are increasingly being used,
which means we then have technologies
for various steps in the
personnel selection process, which are then
mixed with
individual decisions that are part
of the selection process  So this is
a very complex pipeline and
according to the current AI
draft it should now also be this is
an area of ​​application classified as a high-risk area,
personnel selection,
which means that more attention must now
be paid to this topic and
companies will
have to implement something  in the development process you will have to
ensure monitoring. Now
the question that arises is how do
I actually monitor the use of
technologies in the personnel selection process
with regard to
potential for discrimination if I do
n't have this personal data but
how am I supposed to know
whether the use is so I'll say
explicitly now  It's not the technology but
the use of a certain technology that means
that people over 45
hardly have a chance at a certain
job or people who
have a certain type of last name
don't get certain jobs, etc.
if I don't have this information
and that's where it will be  difficult and on
the one hand it's clear that I don't want to give this
information to the potential
employer, but somehow
I have to share it, I would
say now so that you actually know what
the outcomes of this assignment are and
how to resolve this dilemma,
I would  continue to say an
unanswered question that is
hardly addressed in practice. Now we're
back to difficulties. I would
still like to
come back to the opportunities in the medical field.
What kind of opportunities there would be. Unfortunately,
I also have to disappoint
It's a mixed blessing, but I like to start with the
chances.
In the end, there is a lot that we do
n't yet know about how the
human body works, how
diseases work, how they
can become a salary. I'll just give you an
example. It was found out some time ago
that  People with
a certain mutation in their genome have
a higher risk when they take aspirin.
Now I don't remember the German word
colon
cancer, colon cancer, to get exactly colon cancer
and if you know something like that then
of course you can, for example as a doctor, if you
know hey, that  Person has the mutation
say please don't take aspirin take
paracetamol or whatever
similar example a certain
mutation causes children to
convert codeine, an ingredient in a cough syrup, into morfine
to an extent that it
can lead to death  the high
concentration of such information is
super valuable and can actually
save people's lives and there are only
two examples so in the
end you could start
talking about it now and by this
time tomorrow you won't be finished with how many
such connections
have been found  there is everything there and how it
can really save people's lives or cure diseases that have not yet
been cured or can cause
chemotherapy to be chosen that
will have the best effect and the lowest side effects for this person and so
on the problem is that this
data  Not much is collected for the
reasons already discussed that
genomic data is very forgiving and
cannot be changed, but if you
had it, for example every time someone
goes to the hospital,
the genome is added to the patient file
and then the data is stored somewhere centrally
and you can use it  evaluate what
else you would find out about things where people
shouldn't do things or should do them
in order to be able to live much healthier and better.
Such tiny little things
make a huge difference. It's
gigantic. On the other hand,
we've already talked about it
genomic data is very difficult
and genomic data is also super,
super difficult to anonymize because there
are already studies, for example, that have
managed to
predict faces relatively disturbingly well from genomic data
and there were models that identify
people in
image databases based on genomic data, so you
have  a database of ges images you
have a genome and with I think the
publication stated an accuracy of
somewhere around 70 to 80%, the
algorithm can assign the genome to the correct
person and we are only at the
very beginning of
research in this area  means the opportunities are
gigantic and you really can't
say too much gigantic but there are also risks
that you have to think about.
That's actually quite
interesting because this
is an application scenario where
the technology you have actually determines the performance, so to speak
of a human being
because no expert in the world can
make this kind of prediction. A
similar example of this comes
from radiology, where it has been
proven that you can
ultimately predict the
self-identified ethnicity
of people based on so-called chest scans
No radiologist in the world
can, um, but the algorithms
work extremely well, they also
tried to look, okay, it's somehow
on the heart here, heart out of the image, it
still works very well, it's
this fine resolution. Radiologist
still can't do anything with it, we can
do it  The roughly piixelig result is
still extremely good and of course these are
studies that
show what possibilities there are
to make predictions with data
often exceed what we
imagined, that's possible because
no one would normally come up with
the idea of ​​making such
predictions  but you never know
and once it's out there
as a data set then I can
actually
use it accordingly if necessary um and then it becomes
problematic but I would still
like to give a positive example from
my point of view as
we have the covid  -pandemic at the beginning
and we were in a situation
where we had extremely little scientific
knowledge about a relatively unknown
virus, we had the pictures from northern
Italy with full hospitals,
people dying with rigid
measures that were taken to
initially protect the population  There are
debates about collecting data
after you have of course somehow
understood it is about close
contact
and then it was about what types of
contact tracing measures we will
implement.
They developed and implemented the Corona warning app with the
corresponding protocol, which was then
chosen
and they just
decided against a
larger collection of data where
I track where I was, when and where
were other people that I
could actually use for completely different purposes, um, and they just
decided on a protocol that I
don't know  who may
have infected me and where else this person
has been but I can say hey I
'm sick and the people for whom it
is relevant know it and can
behave accordingly and I think that
is a positive example of M
data exchange
but a different one  Type of
data exchange where I don't,
contrary to the principle of
data minimization, collect data
beyond the purpose for which it is
needed. I think it's
central to know what purposes
it is about and then to
think about which data I need for these purposes and
then this  To collect data ethically and
responsibly, let
's stick to the example of what
your club also said, that
was exactly exemplary, absolutely we
worked very intensively in the process of working in the coronawarn app, we
wrote about it  Interviews have
given everything possible to somehow influence exactly
the solution that was now chosen,
which
somehow ended up costing significantly more money
than was somehow necessary, at least in
my professional expertise.
You can
now do that, you can, you can certainly  I'm
still discussing it, but
I think the chosen option was a
very good one and I would still like to see
it was a good example. I
think there is a whole other
category of data where we have very little
risk but huge benefits, that
's not the area  Open data which,
to be honest,
is usually not open at all in Germany, so
we're talking about tree registers, which
are obviously not
personal data but are often stored
in some written form
on some office, which is relatively
bad if I want to do something with it
because I have to  First of all, in the
worst case scenario, make a request via the
Freedom of Information Act that
this data is somehow given to me.
In the worst case scenario, I
still have to pay money for it because
someone has to digitize this data first.
Often it is
still in
file folders and then
I get this data but the data is
there  Then it's not available to everyone,
there's a lot of data that
is available from some authorities, so
we're talking about public data here, which could be wonderful open data
where lots of people
can do a lot of different things with research, make fun apps, something
useful where there's actually no big
risk  so that some
kind of jewelry can be carried out,
but there is a huge potential for innovation
where, unfortunately, our
state simply cannot keep up and that
is really a shame because
we have huge opportunities and
very low risks, so Mr. Selz
would like to know more about trees  know and where
they are and I would like to know whether
questions have already been received. I'm
now looking in the direction of slido, it
's actually there so the topic of
Corona warnpp has now been triggered,
so I'll read the
last question that came up  Was it
really useful
even though we didn't know much about
risk contacts? There are studies
on it and maybe for everyone who
is now at home watching and
wondering why they didn't see that was
Professor Moltagen Schnöring who
said hello at the beginning  it has
our slido in the BCK and is here
in the room but you can't see it right
now m I can't cite studies
that prove how useful the
app is. I would have said that it was
relatively obvious, so of course it depended on
how  many people
used it at what point in time,
there were
peak phases and there were phases where
the app somehow flashed red every day,
but there were also some where you
knew very well that okay, it must
have been such and such a day
or that  and the situation I draw
conclusions from it and isolate myself
I would say that it is
relatively obvious that
if I handle this information
responsibly and take it seriously
that I will be able to
protect myself and
people more  with whom I am in contact,
um, how high the usage
was but of course at what point in time
and how the whole thing
should be viewed from a societal perspective, these are completely
different questions
that also go in the direction of how
we are as a society as a whole
behavior, how solidarity we were
with one another, we wore masks, we
kept our distance, we also
went into the classroom into the seminar in the seminar room with symptoms and
ignored it, so I think
a study situation at this point will also be
difficult. I'm
currently trying to...  I think it's relatively difficult
to present a test where exactly this question is
examined,
but I assume that people who
analyzed the data at exactly this point have tried to
at least get an
overview of how
the use of the app compares with the statistical correlations, so to speak
of
course, you have to say that we have
had very different times in terms
of measurement, testing, financing of
tests, etc. The reason I'm listing all of this
is also to basically show what
data analysis looks like in practice,
you always have the
ideal idea in textbooks like this  You
analyze data
under the idea that I
have all the data I
need to answer a question,
but that is rarely the case and all of the
things I'm listing are now potential so-called
I don't know what's that called
in German confounders, so ultimately
factors that are mine  Analysis
could ruin the analysis so I see a
correlation between two things and I
think aha that's somehow related to that
but maybe both are simply related
to something third, namely
the fact that I simply
tested less and that's why
some numbers go down and that's
um  These causal relationships are
statistically extremely difficult, extremely
difficult to do,
um almost none of the analyzes we do
are in the sense of causality, we
actually always check for statistical
correlations in practice, um that's
also what our machine learning
models usually do, you don't need to worry about
anything  to pretend and for proper
causal analyzes you would need completely different
methods and different conditions.
I would
then most likely have to do such a randomized test
and there are usually
no means or options for this and they are
often not even ethically
justifiable, especially in the medical
field  I can't do it so easily
and say hey, you're
not using the app and you're using
the app now and yes, I'm exposing you to
your higher risk in this
way because you're not well informed
about who's going to be infected
So there are
always a
lot of difficulties with such experiments. We've
already heard a lot about ethical
difficulties about which data we do
n't have available, but which would
be nice if we did have it.
We've talked about data that
we have  all at once or that
someone gets that is in the wrong
hands so it seems to
be a difficult box with this
data are there any regulations
that are missing to make the whole thing a little
better is there anything that
you have come across where you say if it
This regulation would then be really
perfect, it's
probably a difficult question for you,
but
I can now I can say from our
point of view that it is the General
Data Protection Regulation, which I think
is decried in many ways but in other respects
I think it's a really big one,
so personally I think it's very
welcome and I think what what what you the
difficulties with it are,
on the one hand, the unclear interpretation that
we still have in many areas, but
in very big cases it's
simply lacking  In terms of enforcement, there are
blatant data protection violations in
huge quantities and they are simply
not being
adequately suspected and I
actually believe that in this case it is not
the legal situation that is the problem but rather
the legal enforcement, which we
need to significantly strengthen
We also lack skills in
many important places in
society, as well as the
law enforcement authorities, who often also
run around in analogue form in many offices where there is
still a lot of analogue work in
the areas where we are
unfortunately lagging very, very behind
especially when it comes to the
digitization of the state in order to
enforce this set of rules that we
have agreed upon together and for
a good reason because we say data
is something enormously important and it is
worth protecting but if we now
think about what has not yet
been digitized then I would say  I
imagine that at some point we will have such a
huge, unmanageable pile of
data once all this has happened,
we already have it,
and it's not
all digitized yet, so if it
grows more and more in the future and then  is
made up for, there is a
point where you would say that there is now
too much data, now we ca
n't do anything with it anymore.
Too much is relatively too much.
Too much again depends on what
I want to do with this data, I
think if if I  Now after
looking at it, they will probably say
a lot of data, especially from Gomish
research, is, I think, super
better than too little data in that case,
I think the question arises
in whose hands the
data is in and and what data is it  and
how linked are the data, in my opinion,
very acutely, to stick with the example
of the state, there is a
register modernization law as
an example where said if we want
the data that concerns your various offices,
we want to
bring them together in some way if possible  totally
clever and also gives me great
advantages if I go to the office or,
best of all, do it online. It would be
even nicer if I
couldn't always re-enter all the data every time, but rather
the data would be linked somehow,
but of course there is also
the risk of that  a person in
any office who has access to this
data can suddenly find out a huge amount
of data about me where
previously they had to go into 20 different file folders in
ten different offices
so there there it is unfortunately often
the case and and there is  Of course, the
pure data is already
available, but merging them
obviously creates a certain risk and
then controlling that means saying okay,
we might want
our association to demand that before data
is exchanged between authorities, I
am informed, for example, via a data cockpit and can say yes  I
would like
this date to be
exchanged with this other office for I don't apply for an ID card,
but maybe I don't want to
then I just have to re-enter the data,
that's fine, or
maybe ask why, also ask cases
that unfortunately happened in the
area  Stalking Cyber ​​Stalking that
police officers have requested data
from people without there being
a good reason for it and that is of
course a huge risk for this
person and then you ask yourself why
the person was allowed to request this data at all
and that there are just certain things
that at that moment as a
citizen I have the opportunity to say
no, I don't actually want
that person to access my data
and we are basically
introducing control mechanisms to
mitigate this data link because it's a
really good cause but we just have to
see how we do it  Risk then taxes
I think that's much more the question
we talk a lot about risks,
the question is how do
we manage these risks and that's
often said okay then we don't do it or
we do it anyway and we do it
anyway is just great  dangerous,
okay, so here's the suggestion: it
needs to be better controlled. I'll
still repeat the question again:
would there be too much data for both of them
or is that not a problem at all,
so too much data purely from the point of
view of I want to do research on it
and  I want to
find out new things. In the end, it's not possible for me.
It just gets more exciting when there
are so many that you really have to
think about how do
I calculate based on the data so that I
have a result before I retire, but in principle the more data the more
The more you see, the more clearly you can
pull things apart, so from the
perspective no, from the other perspective of the
risks,
yes, but there is something that makes me nervous,
which I have already
mentioned a bit before, we are
only at the very beginning of the journey, it is
It's difficult at this point to even
realistically
estimate what kind of risks
could arise and when we're
talking about things like
people are starting to be able
to reconstruct their faces from
the genome or the same technologies
that are used to
get it out  you
look at the genomes of a large population
and the
clinical pictures which genes
are risk factors for certain diseases
in order to be able to treat people better preventatively, the
same technologies
are used for things like n times
two examples a publication the
vegan gene so you can and you can
Surprisingly, somewhat
based on genetic variants, we can
predict whether people will eat a vegan diet
or not or
the mathematical performance of
students in China.
An experiment such as a study was
carried out and there too they were
able to predict relatively well based on
the genomic
equipment as well  the performance in
mathematics in the classroom was and when
I think of something like that and then what
Helener said about
hiring processes and
discrimination in
hiring processes, that's just the
problem at this
point in time, we are still so far at the
beginning of the journey with the evaluation
of this data  that from my point of view it
is completely impossible
to say reliably whether we are steering in a
utopia or a dystopia and
what we have to do
to set the right course. I
think in the end we can only
sail on sight and we have to be
able to react quickly  When new insights
come and from my point of view that is a
big problem I have to
react very briefly and there is a new
exciting question on slide or
different I got a sign
exactly I find it
exciting because the question is here
again  It's about public data and the
question of how available
public data actually is in Germany
and whether it differs from other countries.
The question here was about
public data for research, but
I think that's fundamentally a
question that probably everyone in the
public domain is asking  The podium
could answer various points of view well,
I think, and what what is public?
Well, exactly what I
wanted to complain about earlier is let
's think about how much
data could you use or would there be
too much somewhere? So what I, for example  I would
still like to have access to what was
once Twitter, but exdata
doesn't exist anymore and now you have
such a huge platform that
is ultimately one of the largest telecommunications platforms, at least for adults or from a
certain age. I think young people
smile at you for using Twitter, but no  There are
relevant
discourses taking place that would somehow be
totally
relevant to analyze at times of crisis,
but you no longer have access to the data
because, yes, I mean, on the one hand, it's
public, but on the other hand, I do
n't really have public access
to it and can't  I don't research them anymore
because Mr. Musk doesn't like it and he ca
n't monitor it well.
I would say that's highly
problematic, but also with other
public data you could also say,
well, local public transport is also
something that somehow
takes place publicly, but it is  Nevertheless, a
company that perhaps provides mobility on behalf of
a
Senate administration
and collects data for it but cannot
simply release this data per se
and it just depends on what type
of data it is and you can't
just say yes BVG or Bahn or
or  whatever should now simply
give your usage data because
conclusions could theoretically be drawn about certain individuals from this usage data. I could
know that a person lives there and there
every day somehow perhaps
drives to this destination perhaps purely from
their demand data to some
routing  App for public
transport if I know that
then I know it's okay but
somehow apparently there isn't anyone in this one
family house
from 6 p.m. to 9 p.m.
every evening so maybe I'll just go in there
and clean them out
or something like that  a
constructed example but you just have to be
very careful about
saying that and that is public data
that you
should release. Double-edged sword
again, we can't get away from it. I would
still like to hear a different
assessment. Public data in
Germany is absolutely not my opinion  There is
a lot of public data in the field of genomics,
but that is international,
I can't say there is German
genomic data, there are others, okay,
understandable,
we basically have
health data that is
less available in Germany than in many
other countries and
attempts are currently being made to counteract this  from the
Federal Ministry of Health but also
there you have to also there we have
criticized a lot because this
project was unfortunately
not designed in a really UMG-friendly way
for various reasons
there is a long statement on this
I don't want to go on too long now
Just talking about the open data example
that I just mentioned
with data that is already in public
hands. We currently have
16 open data portals from the
federal states plus one from the state,
which is kind of stupid
if I might say  I want to
find this data and that means I have to
look at 17 different portals, so I
think we agree on that because the
data is public anyway, so it will be
great if you
have a job and I can search. I
want data about
where it is  all train stations have um and
I can then call up that this is
distributed like that, it
just doesn't make any sense in this case, especially of
course I understand the
different political levels but
I claim that as a normal
consumer I don't have to  I don't
care at what level this
data is collected, but as long as it is
data from the public sector,
it should be made as easy as possible for me
to access this data and that's
where we are
simply very bad compared to other countries.
Okay, that's the question with slido
answered or yes,
unfortunately I can't see that now, I hope so, but as a
follow-up to this, it was also
about the topic of authorities, i.e. how
data
is handled in authorities and whether
data is now linked well,
perhaps too  between authorities,
I read this question here and whether something
could be regulated through an automatic
obligation to provide information, i.e. when
personal data is accessed.
I see the question that the
employees in an authority, for example,
are trained in a certain way  they also have to
deal with it and maybe
then they
also have to deal with certain information,
I don't know, maybe
to you Court
Benedikt, yes, definitely, I think
that is, but that's the
exciting aspect is that the
employees are trained because if so  When
we talk about digitalization, it's
not a
technical problem. We have some
analogue process and are
now digitizing it. In most cases, that's
not what we actually want,
but rather we want the problem that
we have to be solved analogously beforehand
have now been solved digitally, which
usually doesn't mean digitizing one-to-one
and this process has
a lot to do with social behavior
and people have to think like that and
people have to
understand these processes and we are
still particularly lacking in public administration  to want to complain
there's a lot of good things going on
but there's just a lot of things that are
n't going well yet. The entire education sector is a
huge one. I
don't think we need to open it up now
We also understand transformation as a cultural change, we have
to stick together and think a lot in
this direction and not only on a
technological level who
actually has data but also to
look more at which people work with
the data and what do these people have to be
able to do in order to work with it  Being able to work with data
and
work a lot more in this way is
definitely super necessary and very
important, so we have already touched on a few aspects
on the one
hand, which data is
particularly worthy of protection and on  Which
data should we all pay particular attention to?
How is data security actually
guaranteed and who is
responsible for it? But if data
is publicly available or generally
available, how do we manage
to make it publicly available so
that you can do something useful with it?
I have that  I've heard it and I
think a lot of different
other aspects have been addressed and
I would like to
know here on site whether there are any questions,
yes I can already see someone and there
is also a microphone that is already on
the way, we are happy about it
Participation, yes, thank you very much, the area of
mobility is a basic need for me
if I even have a basic right and every
time I rent a car
there is also car sharing with newer cars
Movement profiles
are just passed on and I do
n't have the opportunity as a user to
object to this, that's the legal
form. I'm not a lawyer, but I
would say no, so that's my feeling and
also the feeling that we
share as an association, so we're not
legal advice  or something similar, but
we would also be basically a,
according to our ethical
understanding of digital politics, we say
that is not how we
imagine it and there is a
second question in the audience. The microphone is
already there in the third
row of
heating construction.
Heat pumps are now being used there  The heat pumps will
become the data center of the building, everything will be switched on, whether
we want it or not, I myself am a
heating engineer, we are very interested in
getting the data, but we
can't get to it, but the data act
is now a done deal  The
EU should actually
guarantee us that we, as
craftsmen, also have access to this data that is
collected by industry about the buildings. That was the
reference to the break-in or something like that.
I immediately thought to myself that we
actually know or industry knows
everything that takes place in the buildings,
everything, yes, what about the data act, it
's now 4, 5, 6 weeks old, the EU had
decided that, I heard the
example back then. Airbus has to release to the
Lufthanzer, for example, who sits where, when,
in which seat  Of course
the airline is interested in what
happens to the aircraft and not just
Airbus and that's the same with the
buildings and that affects all of us here.
Thank you for the question. I'll also take a look
in that direction.
Unfortunately, legal questions are really not mine
I, yes, we shouldn't have
invited anyone else to the
topic, but in general I would
say it is of course a great shame if
this one-sided way of using data exists.
No, I can understand your desire to
want to learn something from this data yourself  But
I think there is always very little
participation in data collection like this
and then the data silos are just
in one hand and others can't
access them and I think we don't
develop enough ideas about how
we can collect data in a participatory way and
how we can participate  Such data
can perhaps also be enabled by SAS, the
keyword being a kind of data trust
for various data, so that
a fiduciary administration
may have access to certain data
and allow several accesses
Way to analyze this data
but I don't
store it in private silos of
one facility or a few
facilities. I also think the
people who live in these houses
should have access to what
certain energy data from their buildings
looks like you might also have in
relation to the energy data  a
city, etc. Um, I think all of that
is given little thought in the
regulatory sphere, at least that's my
impression. Even when it comes to something like AI
regulation, that's also something
I see very little, actually don't
see at all, and W I think that you do
But actually you have to invest a lot of
energy and work
because otherwise it simply depends on the interests
of those who help build something like that but
also feed in your data, ultimately
about the fact that they heat houses, that
they drive from A to B,
that they send a text message somewhere
via some messenger  or
send a social media platform, I
generate all this data but have very
little of it directly, so direct
participation is actually not really
provided for and I think
other countries do it better in some cases,
but I would say in the
overall discourse that is simply not the case
correctly
planned I also see another question
especially in the
audience can I also ask a question
back to you for example the one
with the movement profile I find
exciting now I think I'm always too
naive where do you see the problem when a
rental car provider creates your movement profile he
could do that  But also use it
to optimize the offer, where do
you see the risk if that happens, so it
's a completely open question, because it's
absolutely no concern of the rental car operator
where I go and in front of which house
I park and that's purely my
private matter, I can do that
if I have or would have the opportunity
to say okay, I
wouldn't care about that now then I could type but
if I don't care then I have to
have the opportunity to contradict
and I de facto
don't have that, I guess that they do  In the
case V all the arguments about this, you
have to know where the vehicle is in order to be
able to park it if necessary, to be able to
pick it up, to be able to judge
whether someone
has violated the road traffic regulations
because of course if they
somehow,
I don't know, the car somewhere
temporarily  park it where it
was not noticed, so I'm thinking
loudly right now, but it's
also the case when you're driving a car
if you didn't get caught, then
you just weren't caught. Bad luck,
exactly, but if you had it in somehow
for a short time  the spre sink
so now and then you could
see rental bikes swimming in the spray from time to time
then they might want to know that
they were the ones with the rental property
but that doesn't explain why
I absolutely have to track all the waypoints
along which I drive  I
also think the perspective is justified to say,
well, as long as there isn't a clear benefit
and a clear justification for
why I really need it
to offer this service, then
perhaps this data simply shouldn't be included in
the survey if the perspective is
absolutely understandable, too
Desire for participation and transparency, which has
already been echoed here several times,
yes, I can give two more examples of
movement profiles because that, I
think your question is justified, no,
where is the problem then you know it
is Z always sounds very constructed but
Some of the examples do make it
into the press. I don't know. Do
you know the example of the Strava
app and the secret US military base
in Afghanistan? That's STV, it's
a sports tracking app and well, and
then suddenly somewhere in there
Afghan pumpers are carrying out a lot of stv
activities, for example, it could be
concluded that your secret US
military base is what you could
actually read out of this data
and another example that I
found really very problematic was,
I think, called the pillar, which is
a Catholic
news magazine  One of their
priests
came out as being homosexual
because I think it was
the Grinder app that sold so-called
anonymized usage data,
which is what I meant earlier, so you
think I'm only giving my data for
this service
Maybe they also did something else, they
just sold the data on and
from this data it was possible to find out
where this person was and when
because you knew he was at a certain seminar at a
certain time
and then I know
he's okay  one of these
few data points then I have to
look, I just have to look at where
else were these data points and
then maybe I somehow have a
gay b in some specific
city and you have the opportunity
to authenticate this person against their will, which
cost the person his job  And
these are highly problematic
situations, which is why you
think that's actually where the
problem is. I'm just moving from A
to B, but movement data
is extremely high-dimensional, there's
a lot of information in it and it's
extremely difficult to
basically anonymize it
Basically, I can only
motivate you to read the data protection declarations of providers if you have seen them, if you
have time and are a bit annoying.
They are
of course written by lawyers for lawyers
and are terribly readable for everyone else
and that's
really no fun, but often
Things are justified with the famous legitimate interest of the GDPR
where you
can seriously question yourself. Is that now a
legitimate interest and you have
the right to information at any time? Simply
write a friendly email to
the data protection officer and
ask what is legitimate  If you are
interested in which of my data is available and
for what purpose, since when do I
want to have a list of all of this data,
then you can also request deletion straight away,
you can do that as you wish, they
also have to respond within
a reasonable period of time, which is a
great pleasure if you do that  If you
want to do that, we also have
a sample written on our website if someone
wants to do that, even with
Since the data protection
supervisory authority is involved, these are
the res data protection officers, as
a rule, so if you have the time and the desire, just
do it, it's always
enlightening, so
frustratingly but enlightening, we
all have something to do this evening if you're interested and
thank you for your patience, there is still  A
message that has just been
waiting for us for a while, yes, we hear it
without overusing this topic of mobility data here,
but
private car sharing providers versus
public local transport, we
actually have a comfortable situation here in Germany,
we are an open system
no no restrictions on trains
or public transport
as perhaps in other countries that
have introduced e-ticketing
This is also a double-edged
sword as it came about and also the topic
of how do you enforce something legally in
which legal framework are you in
this topic of car plate recognition on the
motorway for any
criminal offenses where you say it ca
n't be true that it's not
there  Data will be passed on if
it is clearly verifiable, this is quite
possible here in other countries
and perhaps
this topic of
sustainability or the data will
definitely not be used by us so that such
offers can prevail against
perhaps others  Offers or something like that, yes, do
you have a very specific
question? A question, yes, in that sense it was
a post like that. I just thought
I wanted to
get someone on board to answer it, but I haven't really thought about the
point of sustainability
yet  It's an important
point because the more data I have, the
more data I have to store and
depending on what I'm processing it for, as I
said earlier, for
advertising purposes, it's mostly purely
monetary interest and I'll leave it up to now whether we
all find that socially sensible and
legitimate
Everyone has their own opinion, it
costs huge amounts of energy and
resources and the question is also whether we want to
and can we afford it in the future.
This is also the case. Let's talk less
about data collection and more about data
processing. Which
data processing is actually
on the ecological side?
Sustainable level and is that what
we can still afford or want in the long term, that's what
I learned today
at burdin Science you
really can't stop learning and I
learned today so in 2027 we could
be in a position to reduce data consumption
the energy consumption for data
is as large as the CO2 emissions of an
entire country like Argentina, which is
somehow quite impressive to
imagine and that was also
a question here at slido,
so thank you for
coming up with it and I  Let's look
at our researchers,
how do we deal with this awareness
that such data of
course generate energy in some form
or that energy is needed to
generate this data and that is also a
question of sustainability?
The question fits perfectly  good for the
zeitgeist where I don't know we
use generative models now
for
everyone for every little thing we throw
on chatgvt because we somehow become too lazy
to write an email ourselves
etc. Yes we are absolutely in the age of
large energy consumption not so
much  I say only through
data storage but above all
through training of algorithms and through
the use of algorithms that
now simply
cost an extremely large amount of energy. There was a
sorry
two years ago, yes, zi years ago, I think there is
now a pretty good paper,
especially in the area of  AI and the
area in the area of ​​the so-called
large language models where in the
end it was actually quite well
assessed how problematic the
whole thing is, especially when it comes to the environmental aspects,
which is also very interesting,
but then suddenly such
large language models
for us  Normal consumers were
suddenly available,
everyone was so surprised by the extent of the
development and the possibilities and
the problems that came with it,
but I would say that this is actually
very critical and the
research is also going a lot in this
direction, especially with the
models  They're getting bigger and bigger, nothing is getting
smaller, so every now and then I do
some research that says, well, it
would be nice
to have a model like that that also runs on my
laptop,
okay, yes, we can all
fine-tune ourselves somehow, but the development  I would say that there is a
tendency towards becoming even larger
models with even larger
contexts that I can feed in that
are trained on even more data
more and
more at conferences that you
have to address such aspects but on the other
hand I think we want to
do reproducible research
but something like GPT models are
in no way reproducible because
you don't even know what
exactly they were trained on
Reproducibility isn't a
concept that makes more sense if
somehow only three large institutions
or five in the world
can recreate it because no one else
has the resources for it. Yes, that has definitely
reached its limits.
I also believe that this is the case  has a little to
do with our collective reaction as a society to the climate crisis and the problems associated with it, which
unfortunately is, um, we stick our heads in the
sand and hope that it goes away even though
we know that it won't go away and what,
in my opinion, is far too little managed
the discussion that if we
want to act sustainably we have to
give up something at some point, we can't always just
talk about it, we want to
maintain our standard of living, we want to do
more and more and better and
at the same time protect the climate - that's
mutually exclusive and
that's a shame  I think that this
discussion is not being conducted at the level
where we say we have these things, they
cost us so much and we
only have so many resources, so
we prioritize and decide as a
society what we should
forego and in what way  The
discussion feels like it's purely emotional
and I mean the simplest
example that I recently
saw again by chance: question with
30 versus 50 in cities where it is well proven
that a speed limit of 30
would somehow save CO2 20% fewer accidents 40%
fewer injuries in accidents
and  I would continue like this but in my opinion I'm
not saying that introducing a
speed limit of 30 km/h would be the only right solution.
Well, my personal opinion,
I'm in favor of it, but people can have different opinions,
that's the beauty of
our democracy. We can all
have different opinions and then
come to a consensus and I would have
no problem with that if we now
came to the consensus that
50 would be retained as standard and only the
exception would be 30s, like now if
that were a consensus that we found
on the basis of the fact that we
discussed it, that we deal with it
we've discussed it and made a conscious decision. We know the costs,
but we're not prepared to
give it up for these costs, but that's
not happening. It feels like
an emotional discussion is taking place and
then someone hits the table and says
no, we're not going to do it and exactly the same thing  What
I find more complex in
the data analysis ST is that exactly this
rational deviation, rational discussion
and then a conscious decision for or
against does not happen, but we
stick our heads in the sand and wait to see what
happens and sometimes it is also
time that thwarts us  the
calculation is the same as today, for example, we do
n't have unlimited time but we
have now talked about sustainability
AI then we just came to the speed limit
it's really we could
move in all directions here I'll take a look
now and say thank you very
much for all your contributions  and
questions for slido about everyone who
has now spoken here, there is
one more question that is urgently on
the agenda. If that is the case, now would be
the opportunity
to briefly raise your hand again, otherwise I will take a look around
here and please  So that
we think about it,
just like Ms. mtagen schnüring said so beautifully,
we know what we
want to bring with us from Berlin science
weak, what did we
bring with us today, what's new now, what are you taking
home with you? I'll start here  a great
task at the end
mhm I have I have learned for myself
I have to deal with the
data act again the last time
I dealt with it was a
few weeks ago so there
I have to I have to deal with it again
and  Then perhaps we also have to
deal with the association again because, um,
maybe now as a final word,
hosts, in short, civil society
needs to participate more
in draft laws when it comes to
data collection, whatever and a
KUS that we see regularly is
a draft law is proposed and  Then there is a
48-hour participation period to
give your opinion, which is
relatively difficult for volunteers, so
if we say we want to
meet somehow, we first have to
read through 256 pages of the draft law and
then we have to
think about it and
send it out  It's not so
easy that
the
Federal Data Protection Commissioner regularly complains about the same topics
that so little time is given to it,
so when I say what I've
learned, I have to deal with the data
more, my wish is for
longer participation periods for
citizens  In the case of
legislative procedures or
data collection procedures,
we have the opportunity
to prevent something worse from happening
or at least to be heard, whatever
that brings, but I
have great hope for that, but it's also
nice that you also
have a work order  have taken them with us
now that we all
know what we're doing this evening and
read all this stuff about why
we give our data where, very nice,
there's a new insight here, a
wish, an
idea, yes what has become more present to me again
is that I invest more time  You
should participate in exactly what you
do,
so you can tell from
the answers and questions that
have come here that there
is a lot of interest,
but we live in a
democracy and it thrives on
us being responsible citizens  and
informed citizens deal with questions
and let our opinion
flow into society
and especially with things like which
data is evaluated by whom, in what
way, for what purposes and where,
that is something where either
we actively enter into the discussion in an informed, mature manner
or leave the playground to
Google, Apple and the financial
press and I think it is
also our job
to motivate and support civil society
in this and it has
become clear to me once again that I
should invest more time in this again, very
good then I wish that too  Have
fun, what's the last idea,
bring the last one with you, yes, actually,
maybe
in the same direction.
I think there's too much burden placed on
individuals and private individuals
when it comes to making the right
decisions. Um, I'm
dealing with the topic of data  and
algorithms every day and it
regularly overwhelms me and I
think that's too much of a burden
that you have to bear yourself
and we take the cookie
banners as an example of such dark
patterns that are implemented that
are not okay and there  Personally, I would like to see
a significant
improvement for the
users. I continue to believe
that our students in the
inform are
hopefully even more interested in
working on this interface of participation and
developing human-centered technology and technology  To take the interests of the
individuals into
account better, to build better interfaces. It's a
shame that my colleague Claudia
Müllerbn isn't here today.
She could have said a lot about that, but I think that's
super important. Thank you very
much. Then I'll say a big thank you
to you all  Thank you
very much for being here at home, thank you
for tuning in and I hope you
enjoy
the next program items at Berlin Science Week and say
thank you to the HTW Berlin for this
exciting event
[applause]
bye